[Music]
good morning
it's seven o'clock you're watching the
only breakfast show live from
westminster now it's a case of planes
trains but not necessarily automobiles
this morning
it seems thousands are set to defy
government advice and jet off to amber
listed destinations for a break
also a massive overhaul of the uk rail
network is on the cards we'll talk to
the man
engineering in all the transport
secretary grant chaps in
just a few minutes also this morning the
recipe for eating well
post lockdown we'll talk to celebrity
chef raymond blanc about the reopening
of his restaurant
and his new recipe book which pays
tribute to his late mother that's
a half past nine for you and no anarchy
in the uk
just live music we'll chat to the sex
pistols glenn matlock who's part of a
sky arts campaign to support small music
venues
that's at 9 45 it's thursday the 20th of
may
this is here for years to come sky news
reports are inside the mental health
units dealing with a massive surge in
children
with acute psychiatric problems she
doesn't come out of a room she doesn't
eat much she needs help she needs
professional
a help for change the government unveils
a timetable to shake up the uk
rail network with a promise of a fairer
ticket system
another extension to england's vaccine
out with more surge testing and surge
vaccinations to curb the
indian variant
conflict in the middle east hamas
officials tell sky news ceasefire talks
are underway but israel's prime minister
vows to press on with the military
offensive
and it's already been very wet so far
this month but we're yet to expect
even more wet weather for today and for
the rest of the week i'll have the
details for you later in the program
well very good morning to you sky news
has been given unique access to a child
and adolescent mental health trust
which sees firsthand the mental health
crises children are facing because of
the pandemic
a hundred children a day are now
attending a e departments
many of them suffering injuries as a
result of self-harm
now those treating them are in no doubt
the pandemic is behind the increase
they blame isolation anxiety and
unprecedented levels of distress
well it's thought that nearly a quarter
of 14 year olds have self-harmed but the
number could actually
be much higher even before the pandemic
rates of hospital admissions for
self-harm for girls rose by 36 percent
that figure doesn't take into account
those in a e
now the latest figures show that
although the first lockdown depressed
the numbers coming to a
e with psychiatric conditions they're
increasing
month on month our people in politics
correspondent nick martin has spent the
last three weeks with the staff and
patients of the pennine care nhs trust
and adolescent mental health services a
warning that his report on their work
does contain references to self-harm
images of self-harm and references to
suicide
it's a very long walk up to the
children's world
and you do get time to think of what
we're gonna see when we get there
nicole renshaw is a mental health nurse
and her patients are children most of
the time the children
have harmed themselves and there are
children on the ward most days
while the nation's been fighting a virus
that's killed so many
thousands of children have been
suffering and the problem has been
slowly
and silently building
this is the children's ward of the royal
oldham hospital
and this is 14 year old laura
she's here because she's deliberately
harmed herself
often children will self-harm or harm
themselves in other ways
to deal with stressful situations
and in laura's case that has definitely
been a factor
laura's mum says her daughter hasn't
been herself for a while now
she doesn't come out of her room she
doesn't eat much
she needs help she needs professional
help
well i go through depression as well and
it comes and goes whenever it feels like
it
so i know what she's going through her
pain
is so raw and i can see the fear in her
face
what do you want to happen now i just
wanted back to normal how she used to be
smiling laughing joking
i have to understand to make sure that
you're safe
life at home in lockdown has been tough
i've never really gone out as much so is
that normal for you to be sitting in
your bedroom
all day long not usually i'm usually
outside with people but
think of it happened and numb
since guava the divorce center reclused
into the bedrooms
and now she stopped eating like i'm
either too busy to eat or
i'm doing something and i'll just leave
about forget about it and wait for later
so just don't bother and how long has
that been going on for
quite a while right our next bit mommy
you're listening
we need to get a safe hour lock on a
drawer all medication
sharps ligatures need to be in that box
okay and then nicole
gently tries to give laura something to
live for
you want to go to college yeah
you want to go to uni yeah i want you to
hold on to that
because it can be done
before the pandemic a e attendances by
children with psychiatric conditions
had tripled in the last 10 years
now month on month those numbers are
continuing to rise
she said she was going to kill herself
looks like she's assaulting mum quite
frequently
this is children and adolescent mental
health services
or calms for short a child who's been
in a e for mental health reasons has to
be seen here
within seven days
and it's in these rooms that they try to
heal
the minds of children we've spent three
weeks here
with unique access to staff and patients
to understand
the pressure the service is under have
you ever done anything like this before
yeah yeah well it started in years
seven hours okay so it's not only for a
few days it's been
it's been six years so it's been for a
couple of years
this is summer she was in a week ago
after harming herself now mental health
practitioner michelle
has to figure out what help she needs
yesterday in english i was like happy
and then like as soon as i went in
spanish i was just crying my eyes out i
literally got sent out
summer explains that her mood can swing
from high
to low so the last time summer south
hound was like yesterday did you say
um are they on barfi around summer just
one just one hour
okay paddle so i'll show you yeah you
can do yeah
so they don't what's that in your hand
what's that yeah
it's a scratching from scratch i have it
though as well
right okay okay i wish i didn't do it
like but these are gonna be scars now
but um i just regret it nothing
it's thought around a quarter of all
children summer's age have self-harmed
it could be much more than that
the cams team is now dealing with a
surge in referrals
self-harm suicide attempts anxiety
it is a grim but growing list of
troubles
dr chantal bassin is the lead clinical
psychologist here
and she's worried about the effect the
pandemic has had on some children
there is going to be a section of people
in our society
who are kind of surviving through this
now and are in total
survival mode and as we come out of the
pandemic
that we're more likely to see the mental
health impact
on those young people and families i
think we might be feeling the tremors
but i think
the impact may well yet to be seen
summer is now being supported by the
cams team here at pennine care
it could be a long careful process
but thousands of youngsters are having
to wait to get to this stage
and for children in crisis there is
often no
time to spare
nick martin sky news
well if you've been affected by any of
the issues in nick's report you can
contact a number of groups one
is the samaritans it's been you can call
them on 116 123
or email joe samaritans.org
now britain's railways are being
overhauled so let's speak to the
man behind the master plan the transport
secretary grant shaps was here in the
studio this morning good to see you
morning so what's happening 25 years
since privatization
now this massive change so what exactly
are we gonna see we're gonna have
one single familiar organization called
great british railways and uh it will
run
uh all the different aspects of the
railway
in order to bring the whole thing
together it's three years
to the week actually since that
disastrous timetable change in
may 18 where the entire system melted
down and when people said
well who's got control of this the
answer was no one there was no guiding
mind there was no as the media used to
like to say fat controller
looking after the railway and today's
reforms what i'm announcing
takes care of all of that with a
familiar brand great british railways
that i think people will
uh you know be pleased to see having
somebody in control
but one of the key points of
privatisation was to separate track and
train
you're saying that completely failed and
bringing it all back together
there are many successes not least that
twice as many people are using the
railways that was a big success of um
privatization
but it became very very fragmented so if
you were to say
whose fault is it that this train has
broken down there are actually 400
people to allocate the blame
within the organization who literally
you
crazy would would have to work out the
size of the bird that hit the oversized
overhead line that
caused the problem and it would be
attributed either to network rail or to
the rail companies it's just
too complicated but i don't want to go
back to the days of british rail
either we had declining passenger
numbers and railway
uh stations closed and things um so this
will be
still with the involvement of the
private sector running the concessions
running the
actual trains but they get paid for
running those trains on time keeping
them tidy and clean
and it will be a single organization
selling you the tickets and
running the timetable but but in terms
of not going back to british rally
again one of the the the supposed
impacts of privatization was that
operating companies would have
um you know their freedom for certain
levels of innovation and what have you
isn't there a possibility here that the
great british rail will turn into a
british rail sort of leviathan well
absolutely not what we
plan to do with this so i you're right
we want to keep the sort of the private
uh you know
initiatives the the capital the
innovation all of that in there
but you've got to have somebody on a
railway which is you know 20 000 miles
of
of track organizing a timetable
organizing
the ticketing making sure that there's a
single body so when you say
when something goes wrong you can say
who is in charge here and there's an
organization and it will be great
british railways
who are in charge so this reform which
is i i see has been widely
welcomed by industry experts this
morning
i think is is is overdue i think you
know as a commuter myself
i just want a railway that works i want
the ticketing to be
straightforward and simple uh and we
won't be going back to the days of
british rail and terrible sandwiches and
all the rest of it
it will be a new organization okay so so
what is the direct benefit for
for passengers then i mean certainly you
want trains to be on time you want them
to be clean obvious i mean that goes
without saying
in terms of the ticketing i mean it is a
bit of a nightmare at the moment and
it's expensive
yeah yeah is that going to show well
that's right at the moment you turn up
at a station there are two or three
different ticket machines you're
supposed to know which one
uh to get if you buy the wrong ticket
you can't use it on this service
all of that gets simplified and you end
up with a railway where
you buy the ticket it can only be the
right ticket because there's only a
uh uh you know you you're buying yes
great british railways
and whichever route you need to take
you'll be able to take
but actually the other thing is crazy
you stand by these machines they print
out goodness knows how many tickets for
a single journey
why we even got paper tickets i mean it
should be contactless and one of the
great things we'll be introducing
um in june next month are flexible
season tickets
because we know that things have changed
people are working from home a lot more
if you're traveling two or three days a
week you'll be able to use these
flexible season tickets
that's only possible because we've
started now on the route towards the
screen i wonder if that is this going to
guarantee
that it's going to be cheaper though at
the moment if i travel into london i
live about 100 miles away so if i travel
in on the train
use one particular network one company
it's cheaper than if i get a ticket that
covers all the companies yeah
now is that price and going to go up to
match the multi
company thing or will it stay at the
lower level no well the great thing is
um
depending on how many days you're
traveling in you might well be able to
use a flexible season ticket to do this
you don't have to work out how many days
you're going to be traveling this week
in advance in order to take advantage of
that and also because it will all be
under
great british railways you can take
whichever route you wish to take
if there were different options and
usually to get from a to b there often
can be
different routes to get there because
it's all part of the same thing
one organization setting the fares
setting the timetable
it's a simplification which i think
people will broadly welcome in this
country
okay um sorry about something which
isn't simple which is the the current
state of the covid pandemic
you can talk about the indian indian
variant um
because we've still got flights direct
flights coming in from india
there was four yesterday at heathrow why
is that happening
you can't prevent british citizens from
returning home no country can ban its
own citizens
are these all british citizens it can
only be a british or irish citizen i
should say or somebody with permanent
residence there's no
it's illegal to come here as a holiday
maker
from from a redless country and you ask
about why the flights are direct well if
you think about it
if you say the country's on the red list
only british citizens
primarily can return but then you say
there are no direct flights then you're
enforcing a situation uh where people
end up spread amongst many other flights
uh and making it harder to carry out the
mandatory hotel quarantine which is
a necessity if you come back from a red
country so there's some logic
and indeed we're actually trialing uh
whether it helps to
have everybody in one place on the same
flight come in and then go straight to
government managed quarantine
um what is confusing you can understand
people being a little bit confused that
the you know we've seen a 28 increase
in india variant since monday
yet the prime minister then saying he's
more optimistic than he was a week ago
about sticking to the june 21st
ah i think it may just be actually the
dates when these
are reported and not the same dates that
are covered so it will have covered a
period before
potentially but we are seeing and this
is what the prime minister and health
secretary both said yesterday
uh that fortunately the vaccines are
working so the
absolute key is people getting
vaccinated and once they are
they are getting covered against all
these variants including this
engine there are three different indium
variants actually this is b16172
that was causing particular concern but
it does actually
you do actually get protected once
you've had that vaccine
last night when we heard from the health
secretary he said and he did cause a bit
of a smile in the office let me tell you
that he said the government advice on
foreign travel has been
crystal clear even you've got a smirk at
that one well
all i was going to say is i announced it
actually friday week ago at a press
conference in downing street
and what i said is actually if it's an
amber or red country
please don't travel for holidays it's
for exceptional circumstances and red is
only for
essentially british citizens uh
returning so i can be completely
consistent and say the same thing today
that is the case we we are saying to
people
you know there's a heck of a lot of
hassle involved
in for example an amber country you've
got to take a pre-departure test you
then have to take two further tests
when you come home yet another one on
top of that if you wanted to
have tests to release after five days
you've got a quarantine
people will come to your house to check
your quarantine i mean it's it's
expensive
it's not we're not at the stage of of
you know
saying to people um go to those places
on holiday in fact please
don't green lists are for holidays and a
little bit of patience
as the world catches up with our vaccine
program will get more of those countries
opened up as green countries well and
yet people are still going and
travel agents and airlines and everybody
else they're still selling the holidays
and the flights
well look we've moved away from a
situation where everything is
it's banned it's illegal i know we got
very used to this last year everything's
banned and illegal and you know
we're we're moving away from that and
asking people to apply
a bit of common sense people asking for
guidance the answer is
actually for a red and amber list it's
not for going on
holiday but and you might say well i
have an amber i mean
i've heard this several times and let me
just explain that every country in the
world is put
into the amber category and then when
the joint biosecurity center look at it
they'll either say actually this country
has a particularly good record they're
doing all the
all the sequencing they're they're on
top of the problem they've got high
levels of
vaccines it's a green country or there
are real problems here it's a red
country
so the default is amber but amber is not
please go and visit there there's a lot
of cost and hassle
and quarantine required when you go to
those countries
and it is being very strictly enforced
um look let's
let's wrap back round to transport if if
we can i say
obviously you want more even more people
to go on the trains with this with this
new great british rail and
i know there's campaigns to get people
back on the buses and what have you
at the moment um what about mass
squaring when people are on
public transport should it happen would
you like to see it happen even if it's
not mandated well
right now you do have to wear a mask on
public transport unless you have a
an exception been very very uh please
impress the vast majority of people who
have been doing it
it's been very good high levels of of
uptake
that remains in place technically it's
in place until the 21st of june as we
know we'll have a
review that's the fourth stage of the
unlock and we'll be able to say more
about it
uh at that time uh but it is in fact the
law at the moment to wear
a mask and that's something that i think
people have just gotten used to
doing people take their keys they take
the wallet that pick up the mask and
they
they leave the home and we're seeing
more people come back to
um transport as i say cautiously but
i hope in one direction we are moving
towards a fuller unlock
okay minister good to talk to you this
morning thank you
well let's get some more on those
changes to the uk's
rail network talk to milena veselinovich
who's at king's cross station
in north london what do people think
molena
well i think most passengers would
welcome a more joined up and accountable
service there's no doubt that
this plan is aimed to putting a stop to
the blame game
when things go wrong when things when
trains are overcrowded or they're late
or they're dirty there'll be a single
body that's responsible for all of that
at the moment
network rail the state-owned government
body is in charge of the tracks while
private companies
are in charge of running the services
and under this new great british
railways
they will be responsible for all of it
this body
will also issue tickets they'll also set
timetables it's not actually supposed to
come into existence until
2023 but some of the reforms will be
rolled out much sooner than that in june
there'll be those flexible tickets that
the minister
was talking about aimed at people who
travel maybe two or three
times a week obviously as a consequence
of the pandemic many more of us will be
working from home
more frequently this new body will also
be
setting out timetables and selling
tickets and the industry has broadly
welcomed this the uh
passenger dog transport fergus said that
people will be
welcoming this new service on the
auspices of
one body but unions are less happy and
they say that this is just
papering over the cracks in the system
okay milano thank you
well still to come for you this morning
just after half past seven we'll talk to
labour's shadow international trade
secretary emily thornbury about her
concerns for a farming deal with
australia
the quarter to eight will be joined by
the man running 110 marathons
in 110 days to raise money
for a local hospice and macmillan cancer
care
[Music]
and with hamas officials telling sky
news intensive talks on a ceasefire
ongoing i'll be joined in the studio by
israel's ambassador to the uk that's at
half past
eight
now surge testing and vaccinations are
being ramped up at six locations in
england as part of continuing efforts to
control the spread of the indian variant
of covet 19.
jamaama walker reports now from hounslow
in west london
hounslow in london is one of the areas
where cases of the indian variant have
been identified
here along with bedford burnley kirklees
leicester and north tyneside
there'll be an amped up program of surge
testing and surge vaccinations
i'm more worried about the effects it's
going to have
on the restrictions the more effects
it's going to have on like local
businesses and things i'm not sure they
can go through
anymore with the lockdowns a lot of
depression a lot of
things that are going on in the
community that's quite worrying for
every single one of them
the variant is thought to be more
transmissible
but there's a growing patchwork of areas
where it's appearing
there are now 2967 cases
known of this variant in the uk and we
are determined to do
all that we can to ensure this new
variant doesn't put our recovery at risk
although the government has increasing
confidence that all the vaccines are
effective against the variant
scientists are echoing the prime
minister's call for a dose of caution
the virus has not gone away i really
hope that you know we can maybe have a
conversation in a few weeks time as
we're approaching the june 21st date and
that's on track but i think if we want
to achieve that
we all need to be responsible and not
push things too far
after this relaxation that we had on
monday morning are you here for your
vaccination yes i am here
we've heard time and time again that
this is a race between the vaccine and
the virus
the vaccine rollout takes another step
forward today as people
age 34 and over in england and 25 and
over in northern ireland are invited to
book their jabs
but there's no doubt that the indian
variant means the race
is becoming that bit tighter jemima
walker
sky news
now could there be an end in sight to
the violence in the israeli-palestinian
conflict
there are reports this morning of talks
at least every ceasefire let's get the
latest from our correspondent
in jerusalem alex rossi what do we know
alex
stephen there are indications that
things are moving in the right
direction obviously the diplomacy the
mediation has been going on
for some time they have also we should
have a caveat here
there have been rumors circulating of
fairly imminent ceasefires
uh earlier this week which didn't
materialize but this does
feel uh slightly different certainly
hamas
officials inside gaza senior officials
are saying that it could come in the
next 24 to 48 hours
israeli media have also been reporting
from israeli officials
that a similar time frame but there have
also been
uh sources suggesting that the israelis
would like another couple of days
uh to continue attacking targets inside
the gaza strip which would obviously
uh prolong things now overnight there
have been exchanges of rocket fire
and israeli airstrikes the israeli air
force have been concentrating
their firepower they say on the
underground
system of tunnels which they have called
the metro this is the tunnels uh that
hamas fighters and other palestinian
militants used to get around
underneath uh the gaza strip to launch
rockets and mortars
into israel so that is continuing and
again the sirens
ringing out in southern israel rockets
still
coming across but it does appear to be
less intense than it has
been over the last few days which
suggests again
that it might be heading in the right
direction but of course the longer this
goes on
the greater the chances for escalation
and of course
the possibility that it could ignite
something far
worse uh perhaps even a dangerous
regional conflict
okay alex for now thank you let's have a
look at some of the other headlines for
you
this morning and people hoping to cross
into spain
gathered in the town of fidec in morocco
and through rocks
and set fire to a barricade after they
were refused permission to cross the
border
moroccan security forces clashed with
the crowd and were able to disperse them
after
some time the clashes came after
thousands of people
including children crossed into the
spanish territory
of quetta illegally
a report into how the bbc journalist
martin beshear landed the
infamous princess diana panorama
interview
is expected to be published today led by
lord dyson
it will conclude whether mr beshear's
actions were appropriate
and if they influenced diana's decision
to give the interview in which
the princess claimed there were three of
us in this marriage
the process has come under scrutiny
after mr bashir
we found out mocked up fake bank
statements which she allegedly used to
gain access
to princess diana
new research suggests younger people
who've had coronavirus are amongst the
one in seven
adults that go on to suffer long covid a
u.s study found 14
of those under 65 had at least one new
condition that required medical care
within three to six months of
contracting the virus
okay this is sky news breakfast let's
see what the weather's going to do for
you today good morning there's
good morning good morning it's looking
pretty
unsettled once again for today it's not
showers this time it's wet
and windy conditions spreading eastwards
across many parts of the uk island for
today
and for tomorrow
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning it's so far this month it
has been very wet and we continue with
the wet weather for today and for the
rest of the week as well as that
it is going to be very windy as well the
met office do have a warning in force
actually from
this evening into the end of tomorrow
for
central and southern parts of england
and wales where there could be gales or
severe gales particularly around
southern and western coast
currently there are spells of rain
across ireland northern ireland wales
and southwest england that will all move
north eastwards through today with the
heaviest and most persistent downpours
across northern ireland northern england
and
wales there ain't more patchy elsewhere
and a bit brighter later around central
southern and eastern parts of england
but still some heavy showers
likely as i mentioned very strong winds
particularly around southern and western
coasts
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
nas thank you still to come on sky news
breakfast we're going to be talking to
labour's shadow international trade
secretary
emily thornbury
our scientists tested reusable masks for
how well they filtered particles how
breathable they were and how they fared
after
multiple washes but as you rightly said
we found
a wide range in effectiveness all the
way from being able to block
99 of potentially harmful bacterias
all the way to only a third of particles
being blocked
in the worst performing masks i think
what was worrying for us was that there
were high filtration claims made on the
packaging of these masks
um and yet they didn't live up to tests
so if people are looking for maximum
effectiveness and protection because
they are worried actually what they're
able to buy isn't really clear for them
um and
they aren't actually living up to the
claims that they're making we also saw
poor packaging instructions across a
range of these masks
which actually could um again inhibit
the maximum effectiveness all the way
from how you should be using the mask
so that you can be as safe as possible
and then also those washing instructions
if they are reusable you want to be able
to wash them what happens after you've
washed them a couple of times what
happens to that effectiveness
so really the key thing here is that are
these um
products that are housed in the market
really living up to those claims so
people can
make their own decisions about how
effective they want their masks to be
one of the uh most popular ones that we
saw was the adidas face covering
it's widely available from stores like
asos next
sports direct but that only blocked a
third of potentially harmful bacterial
particles
um whereas the best performing that we
saw
was the air pop pocket and it's a
semi-reusable mask
but it had up to 99 filtration
effectiveness
um so you can really see the wide
disparity of mass that you can find on
the market
um and really means that people need to
do a lot of research before they
they look to buy a mask
[Music]
let's return to one of our top stories
this morning and surge testing and
vaccinations are being ramped up at six
locations in england as parts of
continuing efforts to control the spread
of the indian variant of covid19
earlier the transport secretary told us
that vaccine take-up was
imperative to curb the transmission of
new variants
we are seeing and this is what the prime
minister and health secretary both said
yesterday
that fortunately the vaccines are
working so the absolute
key is people getting vaccinated and
once they are
they are getting covered against all
these variants including this
engine there are three different indium
variants actually this is b16172
that was causing particular concern but
it does actually
you do actually get protected once
you've had that vaccine
uh well let's talk to our political
correspondent kate mccann what do you
make of that kate
well i think what's really interesting
here is the contradiction if you like
between what grant chaps was saying when
it comes to ambulance countries because
he said you know i've been very clear
you shouldn't be traveling to an amber
or at least country for a holiday that's
the government's message
but at the same time over the last
couple of days some ministers have said
yes you can
you can go if you've got a particular
reason and we know that there are lots
and lots of people booking flights or
holiday companies offering really cheap
deals to some of these countries so
people are doing it we know they're
leaving the country
but at the same time the government
pretty battle the home secretary is
saying
we're going to send someone around to
your house you could potentially be
fined 10 000 pounds if you found not to
be quarantining
and they could do 10 000 of these
checkup visits a day
now that sounds like quite a strict
system doesn't it but grant shaps was
saying well we're moving into a stage
where we want people to take personal
responsibility
we want them to think really carefully
about their choices so those two
messages don't necessarily seem to fit
alongside each other
i think the reality is though things are
looking more positive he
said you know like the prime minister
did last night june 21st looks like it
could be okay
still a bit more data needed but
generally it looks like the vaccination
is working
and if that is the case i think the
government is going to be more relaxed
about travel to some of these countries
as we see that the vaccine
is going to protect against these
variants and he said you know it's
protecting us
all three of the indian variants at the
moment so potentially good news as case
rates stay low but
still a little bit of confusion i think
about what the overall message is okay
kate thank you let's get some morphe now
on the conflict in the middle east and
hamas officials have told sky news
intensive talks on a ceasefire are
ongoing
now since the israeli-palestinian
conflict began more than a week ago
228 palestinians and 12
israelis have been killed now on the
palestinian side that includes
66 children we know that
a five-year-old jewish child also died
let's talk to caroline ort she's the
country director at the norwegian
refugee council offering trauma care
to some of those children who have now
lost their lives that
what is the situation actually on the
ground there
the situation is still extremely dire
we hear even last night the shooting
in both directions continued so we have
a significant number of our staff
who've had to leave their homes who had
to leave their apartments due to
the risk of being being destroyed or
already having been having been
seriously damaged
so we have very limited access uh
to the two areas in the gaza strip we
know over 40
000 people have sold refuge in emergency
shelters
which are basically schools that have
been transformed
into shelters but it's extremely
difficult to
to provide any kind of humanitarian
assistance until there is a ceasefire
but we know don't we that that because
you've been working in the region for
quite some time as an organization and
dealing with the trauma that some
children palestinian children have gone
through
over the years and some of those
children you've been working with have
now
been killed haven't they as a result of
these strikes
yes so far we have the information that
11 children
11 of the 64 66 children that have
uh that have died in the uh in the
fighting
in the as a result of the of the bombing
um were beneficiaries of our trauma
counseling program
yes these are children who have already
lived through
um some already through the 2014 or 20
2009 hostilities
some in the course of the last couple of
years
a lot of them have suffered severe
trauma and we fear that
after after ceasefire when
when things go back to a slightly more
normal situation
the the level of trauma will be
significantly higher
yeah look i'm not wanting to play the
the blame game with you in in any way
share performance it's not it's not
appropriate for
for your role and your position but i
wonder when you look at
what is happening um within
gaza city particularly and along the
gaza strip
there is so much decimation of of
of key buildings and key infrastructure
how can life there even continue when
this
ceasefire actually kicks in if it kicks
in
it's a good question um
what we what we are pushing for
as a international community
humanitarian community
is that a ceasefire is not a ceasefire
shouldn't be the end of it but we need
to go towards the situation where gaza
can actually become uh that the gazans
can
resume a normal life which they haven't
been able
since since the siege on gaza started in
2007.
people can't leave and part of the
damage part of the
incredible damage and con
what's what the destruction
is a result of the fact that people
cannot leave
and so until that changes until there is
a lasting solution
for the civilians for the people living
in the gaza strip
um it's it's any solution will be will
be piecemeal
um okay look caroline we really
appreciate your time today thank you
hi pleasure thank you steven uh let's
talk to the shadow international trade
secretary emily thornbury
it's good to see you this morning can i
just ask you just to start with on on
the
the israeli-palestinian situation i mean
obviously there appears to be some move
towards a ceasefire
hamas saying it's it's it's negotiating
israel at the moment binyamin netanyahu
saying he's just going to continue i
mean what
what should we be doing as a country
we absolutely have to get behind the
calls for an international ceasefire
both sides need to stand down we do need
to be mindful though
that in a way this is not a kind of
equal fight
and the um and the extent of bombing in
gaza is
frankly appalling heartbreaking
but there is no excuse for hamas to
continue to
send shells into israel you know if we
believe in a two-state solution that
part of israel that they're shelling
is the part of israel which is accepted
as being part of israel in the end this
is not part of
occupied territories per se there is no
excuse for it there's no excuse on
either side
and in the end those that suffer are the
civilians i don't want
little jewish children or in in israel
or little palestinian children
in in gaza to go to sleep at night
afraid they might not be able to wake up
it's appalling what's going on
disgraceful um look classy about the
the brexit situation because i know
obviously you've you've raised concerns
about this
australia deal now it's important that
we're
striking our own deals as a key part of
brexit a key part of why we why we
wanted to get out
on the surface a free trade deal sort of
sounds great doesn't it
but there are concerns about the impact
it's going to have on farming here in
the uk
what do you want to see so first of all
i don't want it to be framed as brexit
you know you almost hear from ministers
somehow that you know we left the
european union
therefore what's the point of having
done that if we don't strike up deals
around the world
can we just like wheel away from this we
are where we are we're out of the
european union we now do
trade deals but let's do them in a
grown-up way we're not doing them in
order to prove we can do
trade deals or stand in front of british
flags and shake people's hands
we're supposed to be doing deals that
are to the advantage of this country
and i have to say i don't think there is
likely to be a country around the world
that is going into a deal saying well
yeah it may decimate our farming
industry but to be honest we need to
have a deal in order
to prove some political point so we do
need to deal with australia though
we do need a trade deal of some
description well it would be it would be
a good thing to have of course it would
and i think we can get one and i want us
to
but we have to do a deal which is in the
interest of our country what's the point
in doing one that isn't in the interest
of our country
why would we want to undermine our
farming industry
why do we want to do that of course we
don't want to we have high standards in
our country
of animal welfare food production
standards and we don't want that
undermined
by cheap imports of food that is not
produced to the same standards
and frankly i don't think that it isn't
just farmers i don't think any of the
british public want that
and so a deal is there for the having
but we need to be
we need to have our offensive asks we
need to be defensive
we need to have a trade policy which
says what are the opportunities for our
country
what is the way we want to go let's have
a trade deal that actually bolsters that
and supports it
doesn't cut across it because we need to
make some sort of political point
well look the idea of a trade policy i
think will be welcomed
by a lot of people absolutely but what
about any labor policies or anything
you know after after what we saw the set
of elections
which were not good for the labour party
on the whole and
i mean one of the key criticisms coming
out before and after polling day
actually was that you were not
presenting really any solid policy
is that going to change well i think it
was a mixed picture there were certainly
some results that we really i mean i
regret losing any
of our of our counselors or elected
representatives some in some places we
did really well in some places we didn't
do well of course
we certainly would want to do better we
need to do better in the future
and we are developing policies i can
talk to you if you've how long have you
got i'm
quite happy to talk about labour's trade
policy i mean in the end what we need to
do
as i say is you start off by saying we
haven't had a trade policy in this
country for
50 plus years because the european union
basically did it for us
so now that we're out to the european
union we need to work out
how to what is what are the priorities
for our economy and how do we get a
trade policy
should you have all this out before the
election shouldn't you well to be
do you know what we've got an
international trade secretary who hasn't
got a trade policy at the moment so
excuse me
i mean no i mean all you know her trade
policy is just sign up to as many deals
as possible
and never mind what it is that you're
signing up to what a trade a trade deal
in the end
says we will make it easier for our
market to be accessed by
whatever industry it is now obviously
that will always have an impact
on your domestic industry in turn we
need to be thinking
right we want to have access for i know
a particular part of our industries
which we see a future in and we feel our
economy is going to grow into
and we make sure that a deal gives
access to that particular part of our
economy
that's how you need to do it but you do
need to have an overview and you need to
have a vision
what what would you like to see
differently done then in terms of policy
over
where we are in covert at the moment for
example on the you know
the travel system that we have which is
causing a lot of confusion at the moment
yes i honestly don't think that since
coved started that this british
government
has had the right policy when it comes
to international travel
i think that they have been reckless you
can just you just hear these terrible
stories
of people coming in through heathrow and
spending three or four hours
queuing with people from green countries
yellow you know
amber countries red countries all mixed
up together and then you know the people
from the red countries go off and
spend time you know in hotels but
they've already spent four hours cheek
by jowl
in presumably in some great petri dish
you know potentially bringing in lord
knows what into our country
i think and the labour party thinks that
we need to pause this
we need to stop it we certainly need to
stop this idea of amber countries
and we need to be much stronger about it
pause it and have a look again
at our truck but but really be much
stricter about it
and that kind of links into the point
which is
we're doing really well thank goodness
for our national health service thank
goodness for our scientists you know we
are all getting ourselves vaccinated in
this country
but in the end we're only as safe as our
neighbors around the world are
and what we need to have at g7 is we
need to have boris johnson showing some
real leadership
bringing countries together and getting
an international plan
on how we're going to make sure that the
world is vaccinated and today
me and my colleagues have written to the
government and said we have a 10-point
plan on what it is that you should do we
give this to you
as a plan we have to make sure that we
have more vaccines
and we think that as a way of doing that
and we're trying as
a as a responsible opposition to help
but they do need to start listening
well we shall see if they do listen
emily thornberry good to see you this
morning nice to see you too
well still to come on sky news breakfast
in just a couple of minutes we're going
to be joined by the man
running 110 marathons in 110 days to
raise money for charities
impacted by the pandemic
[Music]
our job is to tell the truth this is a
forgotten front line
they are dying here
[Music]
boy we've got some interesting ways of
showing you what's going on their
message to us
get ready instructing you to stay at
home
i can't believe we did that it's pretty
special isn't it
i'm adam parsons i'm skye's europe
correspondent based here in brussels
more flares going off a volley of rocks
bubbles have been pulled up out and have
been used as missiles to help
at these police
we take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place
for news we have now
left italy and entered france nobody's
asked to check our identity
[Music]
made by people who dare to challenge
nice to see you again mr barney
why not committing you fishing does have
the potential
to stymie an enormous economic deal
what strikes you when you come to this
glacier is not just the way in which the
environment is changing
but the speed at which those changes are
happening
it's devastating actually
for the early risers
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news entertainment podcast
for wherever you are welcome to
safety rage watch monday podcast for the
ones who want to know more welcome to
the all-out politics podcast
for the listeners
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free did you know symptoms of hay
fever can develop at any stage of life
not just in childhood the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
rain and strong winds will spread
eastwards today with the heaviest and
most persistent downpours across
northern ireland
northern england and wales it'll be
windy too especially across southern and
western coasts
with gales or severe gales later tree
pollen is still mainly airborne at the
moment but there are small amounts of
grass pollen now too
levels of pollen will be generally low
today because of the unsettled weather
the pollen reports sponsored by philips
connected air purifiers
now gary mckee is running he's running
his 109th
marathon in as many days today to raise
money for macmillan and hospice at home
at west cumbria he's running his 110th
tomorrow and then hopefully hopefully
he'll have a rest he joins us now he's
in cleta moore good to see you this
morning
i mean you must be crackers gary 109
well 109 today you must be looking
forward to tomorrow and getting it all
done and dusted
yeah looking forward to elaine actually
uh but no
people think it's tougher than it
actually is um
it to me it's just running the
incredible
part is the funds
that are coming in and how much money
we're raising
yeah i know you are you are chalking up
a lot of money and
macmillan is particularly important to
you isn't it
yeah i mean dad was diagnosed with
cancer in 1997
and he was a cancer survivor but i just
remember when he passed away
that i wanted to do something in memory
of my father and i thought back to
the day that we were told he had cancer
and how many people were being told that
devastating news
i wanted to be able to raise funds and
give them the support that they require
yeah yeah um look in all of this
you are raising a lot of money but i
mean you are also getting into the
record books aren't you i think
aren't you smashing the record for the
number of consecutive marathons
yeah the guinness world record is 59 um
i'll do 110.
i think the problem with guinness is the
verification of it they ask you
questions like who measured your course
out and
who witnessed your own it and things
like that so it was never really about
records it was just about
raising the awareness and as much money
as possible
i i was going to say because haven't you
haven't you run a hundred
before in 100 days
yeah previously in 2017 around 100 100
days
to celebrate it would have been my dad's
80th birthday
and it was 20 years since his diagnosis
so i decided to
18 20 100 will run 100 marathons of
course you
in all of this i have to say as a
cumbria and i'm i'm from dalton
uh down the down the bottom end so so as
a cumbria i think you're flying the flag
for a lot so you do
you're doing is proud are you getting a
lot of cumbrian support
we see i run on a cycle path every
morning and we see the the same paper
and
they show up they all cumbrian words it
is like keep hussing on
which means keep going do your best to
keep going and we get that every morning
it does pick you up you know the same
people shout and it's great
tell me about the trainers because i
know you you've worked your way through
a lot of trainers and you've had some
some really good people helping out
haven't you
i have yeah i'm running um especially
cushion trainers
hawker um probably the most question you
can get and
they do cost you quite a bit of money
and when people found out how many pairs
i was using
they started buying me running shoes and
running tights and things so it has
saved me
a small fortune in in gaia which is
incredible from
the local community and further failed
and much appreciated by myself
yeah well look good luck gary for today
even
even more look for tomorrow and have a
point on us when you uh we'll send you a
fiver up have a part of those when
you're done
brilliant thanks very much it's a good
solid fell of that
now let's have a look at the weather for
you here's nice
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning incredibly wet and windy
conditions across many parts of the uk
and ireland for today and for tomorrow
and in fact
for the rest of the week we continue
with this unsettled spell of weather
it is really looking quite wet and so
far this may uh
it has been uh very wet with above
average rainfall now currently
there are spells of rain across ireland
northern ireland wales in the southwest
dry elsewhere with some sunshine still
across some eastern areas where it's a
chilly morning
with a local grass frost that rain
moving its way north and east was
through this afternoon
with the heaviest downpours across
northern ireland northern england and
wales winds also
strengthening later with gaels or severe
gails likely around southern and
western coastal areas
the weather sponsored by qatar airways